Eine Raumstation in einem ausgehöhlten Asteroiden?
Humbug oder realistische Idee?
Ein Team aus Astrophysikern hat jetzt berechnet,
ob diese Science-Fiction Idee umsetzbar wäre
- und das Ergebnis ist mehr als überraschend.
Wie also können wir uns eine Raumstation
in einem ausgehöhlten Asteroiden vorstellen?
Clixoom Science & Fiction hier gibt es täglich
spannende Science-Videos - - abonniert den
Kanal, nur dan verpasst ihr nichts herzlich
willkommen!
Manche Fachleute sind sich sicher: Das sogenannte
“Space Mining” könnte mal eine der größten
Industrien des 21.
Jahrhunderts werden.
Das Potential ist jedenfalls gegeben.
Berechnungen zufolge könnte nämlich ein
etwa ein Kilometer großes Objekt den heutigen
Bedarf an Industriemetallen decken - und das
für Jahrzehnte.
Die NASA geht davon aus, dass alleine im Asteroidengürtel
zwischen Jupiter und Mars Gold, Nickel und
Eisen im Wert von etwa 700 Quintillionen Dollar
zu finden sind.
700 Quintillionen - das sind unglaubliche
20 Nullen an der 7 - wow!
Und mittlerweile ist an dem Thema nicht nur
mehr die NASA dran.
Sondern auch Weltraum-Bergbau-Unternehmen
und Auch einige Start-ups.
Und so gibt es schon jetzt Geschäftsmodelle
für den Weltraum-Bergbau.
Das langfristige Ziel ist es dabei nicht nur,
Material abzubauen und zur Erde zu bringen.
Die Rohstoffe könnten außerdem auch direkt
im Weltraum genutzt werden - und zwar für
Aufenthalte dort oder längere Reisen.
Bei der Umsetzung wäre eine Raumstation enorm
sinnvoll- und zwar direkt an - oder besser
gesagt direkt IN - den Zielobjekten.
Konkret könnte beispielsweise ein Teil eines
Asteroiden ausgehöhlt werden, um dann in
seinem Inneren eine Raumstation aufzubauen.
Das hätte direkt einige Vorteile, die den
Abbau von Rohstoffen enorm vereinfachen würden.
Im Inneren eines Asteroiden beispielsweise
wären die Astronauten vor der kosmischen
Strahlung geschützt.
Und: Nach dem Abbau der Rohstoffe könnte
man den Asteroiden in Rotation versetzen.
Damit würde dann eine künstliche Schwerkraft
erzeugt.
Klar, das klingt erst einmal nach Science-Fiction
pur, doch völlig ausgeschlossen ist das ganze
Projekt keineswegs.
Astrophysiker der Universität Wien haben
diese Zukunfts-Vision jetzt einmal genauer
analysiert.
Als Basis für ihre Berechnungen haben die
Fachleute einen hypothetischen Asteroiden
mit einer Größe von rund 500 mal 390 Metern
ausgewählt, der künstlich in Rotation versetzt
wird.
Asteroiden solch einer Größenordnung existieren
tatsächlich in der Nähe der Erde - das Physikerteam
benennt in seiner Studie beispielsweise “3361
Orpheus” und “99942 Apophis”.
In den hypothetischen Asteroiden aus Silikatgestein
würde laut den Berechnungen ein Hohlraum
geschaffen - und zwar in einer Größe von
200 mal 300 Metern.
Hier könnte dann eine Raumstation errichtet
werden.
Damit die Gesundheit der Astronauten-Teams
dort nicht gefährdet wird, müsste der Asteroid
laut der Experten ein bis drei Mal pro Minute
um seine Achse rotieren.
Dies hätte eine Schwerkraft zufolge, die
der Schwerkraft auf dem Mars ähnelt: etwa
38 Prozent der Schwerkraft auf der Erde nämlich.
Dazu Thomas Maindl aus dem österreichischen
Forschungsteam: “Unsere Berechnungen zeigen,
dass die Belastungen durch Fliehkräfte eine
Raumstation in so einem Asteroiden möglich
machen, ohne dass Spannungen zu einem Zerbrechen
des Körpers führen".
Doch die Wissenschaftlerinnen und Wissenschaftler
betonen auch, dass ihre Berechnungen nicht
als Basis für eine endgültige Entscheidung
dienen können.
Ob sich solch ein Objekt tatsächlich für
den Einbau einer Raumstation anbietet, könnte
alleine eine Mission vor Ort zeigen.
Diese würde nämlich dann auch wichtige Erkenntnisse
zu der internen Struktur und Zusammensetzung
des Asteroiden liefern, die uns bislang noch
fehlen.
Die größten Gefahren aus dem Weltraum.
Draufklicken, anschauen und AstroComic-TV
abonnieren.
Cooler Kanal.
Ansonsten bis dann, bleibt dran!